yo the other thing we did on the air
that
we weren't crazy about was something
called the celebrity smash oh man
so we had a bit called the celebrity
smash which in theory is an amazing idea
uh and it was where we had people call
in
and give us stories about times they
[ __ ] celebrities celebrities
and this was our boss doc winter's idea
and it and
he had tried it with the breakfast club
and and and the problem was
was it it was a great idea but to
execute it without putting people's
names out there or trying to make it
too obvious that people knew
because at the end of the day you want
listeners to be in on it yeah
yeah so we it got to the point where we
had to edit so much of these calls we
were getting that it was so like
bland and and kind of took away from the
original
appeal of the bit yeah no i think the i
think the celebrity smash will work
in 1998 if you know i think it'll work
now just you have to you have to say who
it is
you got to but the only problem is you
can't do that now because because people
will be
yeah slander and yeah all kind of stuff
bro if you can say who it is it'll work
listen we had some guy call
the first week we did this thing we did
the
which oh [ __ ] i'm not talking about this
one
yeah yes are you go ahead i'm not going
to say who who who he said oh okay okay
but we had this guy calling
and he told us a story about
12-minute phone call it's a 12-minute
phone call we still got the call
about this a man who called
and talked about his
sexual relationship with a very
prominent
mogul in hip-hop yes and gave details
details extreme details in which
made it extremely believable with this
guy 100
and when i say it had us like
because because we started that bit and
almost right away we got that call and
we were like
oh this [ __ ] about to be crazy
this [ __ ] about to go crazy yeah i like
well we about to get into so much
trouble
and the person in which this guy put on
a blast is someone
who you don't want to [ __ ] with in in i
don't want no smoke
no smoke so
right so we send we send it over to uh
our boss and he's like you gotta take
this out take this out take this out
take this out take this out cool
it ended up still being very appealing
on the air
but that bit could have if it was like
99
and we were doing that bit and we were
letting these names fly
oh a lot of the people who called it was
just run-of-the-mill groupie [ __ ] i was
in san diego with
my girl and i didn't [ __ ] whoever the
[ __ ] right
oh yeah of course you did of course you
did
or but then there was there was some no
there was a couple there was a few
that were kind of crazy kind of crazy
and a lot of it too was because like
these people would be married or
there would there would be some sort of
remember the the family the the girl
from the big family with the nda
yes yeah bro the girl from the big
family with the nda i do remember yeah
yeah and and and mind you who knows
if these people were telling the truth
but we got bro
that call about that uh mogul was that
[ __ ] was crazy
crazy i still be playing that [ __ ] for
people you do oh yeah i'd be like yo
i don't play it for nobody
in the event this [ __ ] leak i don't know
i've destroyed it
but yeah that was that was a wild uh i
was a pretty wild wild bit we did
yeah we ended up not doing it because
they just kind of got too watered down
and then
we got in trouble a bunch we stay you
know what i've never been in trouble so
much in my life and doing the show with
you
yeah i mean every time they say yeah i
mean you know no i don't know
[ __ ] stayed in the principal's office
like [ __ ] what we do
ah [ __ ]
he said